Çeviri: Ahmet Erdogan Asliyuce
Gözden geçirme: Batuhan Çevik
Güzel bir şeye başla.
Ama hep güzel olsun.
Çünkü her insan ölecek yaşta.
Geç kalmayasın…
Şems-i Tebrizi’nin bu dizeleriyle
ilk karşılaştığımda
belki de en zor zamanlarından
birini yaşıyordum.
Uzun süredir Türkiye’nin en önde gelen
gruplarından birinde çalışıyordum.
İşime ve çalışma arkadaşlarıma
gönülden bağlıydım.
Ancak yüksek tempo ve stres,
aşırı uykusuzlukla birleşti
ve ben maalesef tükenmişlik
sendromu ile tanıştım.
Bu rahatsızlık kendini bende
tarif edilemez bir baş dönmesi
olarak göstermişti.
İşimden düşmeye başlamıştım,
hareket kabiliyetim oldukça azalmıştı
ve bu beni gerçekten
çok rahatsız ediyordu.
İş yaşam dengesini tam
oturtamayan biri olarak
işimden ayrılıp biraz kendime zaman
ayırmam gerektiği aşikardı.
Fakat bu kararı vermek
benim için hiç de kolay değildi!
Sonra şunu fark ettim.
Şirketim kısa zamanda benim
yerime birini bulabilirdi,
hatta benden daha iyi
birini de bulabilirdi.
Ama bu ailem için geçerli değildi.
Bir gazeteye ilan verip yeni bir oğul,
yeni bir eş arıyoruz diyemezlerdi.
Benim başka sorumluluklarım da vardı.
İşte bu farkındalıkla,
benim için o zor ve üzücü
kararı almak durumunda kaldım
ve işimden ayrıldım.
Sonrasında çok bocaladım.
Baş dönmem azaldıkça kendimi daha
büyük bir boşlukta hissediyordum.
Ve her gün kendime şu soruyu soruyordum:
“Evet Emre, şimdi ne yapacaksın?”
Hatta sırf kendimi
daha iyi hissedebileyim diye
yeni bir kurumsal kariyer için
görüşmelere bile başlamıştım.
Ama o dizeler bir türlü
aklımdan çıkmıyordu.
"Her insan ölecek yaşta,
geç kalmayasın"
Sanki Şems-i Tebrizi beni dürtüyordu.
Şu hayatta biraz da kendine,
hayallerine zaman ayır diyordu.
Ve evet, benim de her insan
gibi hayallerim vardı.
Ama itiraf etmeliyim hayallerimi hayata
geçirme konusunda problemler yaşıyordum.
Örneğin kendimi bildim
bileli bir deniz tutkunuydum.
Son yıllarda yelken sporu
ile ilgilenmeye başlamıştım
ve en büyük hayallerimden biri
Atlantik Okyanusu’nu geçmekti.
Ama bende tık yoktu.
Hani bazen bir kitapçıya gideriz,
çok sevdiğimiz kitaplar satın alır,
eve döndüğümüzde onları büyük
bir özenle raflarımıza dizeriz.
Ama okuyacak zamanı bir türlü yaratamayız.
Sanki benim zihnimde de hayallerimin
dizili olduğu bir kitaplık vardı
ve ben henüz hiçbirinin ilk
sayfasını bile açmamıştım.
İşte Atlantik geçişi de
zihnimdeki bu kütüphanede
üstü tozlu şekilde beni
beklemeye devam ediyordu.
Kim bilir belki hayal etmek,
harekete geçmekten
çok daha kolay geliyordu.
Belki de tek problem,
nasıl harekete geçeceğimi bilmememdi.
Bu konuda net bir fikrim yoktu.
Sonunda bir karar verdim,
kervan yolda düzülür dedim
ve bu seyahat için gerekli
adımları atmaya başladım.
Ve ne oldu biliyor musunuz?
Bu hayalimi gerçekleştirdim.
Atlantik’i geçtim.
Türkiye’ye ilk döndüğümde
arkadaşlarımın bana
“Emre başardın, okyanusu geçtin”
dediklerini daha dün gibi hatırlıyorum.
Ama şunu da çok iyi biliyorum.
Olay sadece okyanusu geçmek değildi.
Orada başka bir şey daha olmuştu.
Geçmişteki Emre’yi kökten değiştiren
ve onu geleceğe hazırlayan bir şey…
Okyanus, bana hayatta nasıl
harekete geçebileceğimi öğretmişti.
İşte bugün bu yüzden buradayım.
Sizlere bana okyanusun fısıldadığı ve
nasıl harekete geçebileceğimi öğrettiği
o üç maddeli formülden
bahsetmek istiyorum.
Madde 1: “Temet Nosce”
Temet Nosce, Latince bir söylem olup
“Kendini bil” anlamına geliyor.
Belki bazılarımız buna
Matrix filminden aşina olabilir.
Hatırlarsınız, Morpheus
Neo’yu sistemden kaçırıyor,
çünkü onun seçilmiş kişi
olduğuna inanıyor.
Sonra onu kâhinle buluşturuyor.
Kâhin ve Neo’nun o ünlü buluşma
sahnesi mutfakta gerçekleşiyor.
Ve beklenenin aksine
ilk soruyu kâhin yöneltiyor:
“Ee Neo, sence sen o seçilmiş kişi misin?”
Neo büyük bir açıklıkla
bunu bilmediğini söylüyor.
İşte o zaman Kâhin mutfağın eşiğinde asılı
o ahşap tabelayı gösteriyor.
Orada "TEMET NOSCE" yazıyor.
Ve Kâhin şöyle devam ediyor:
“Kendini bilmek, âşık olmak gibidir.
Kimse sana âşık olup
olmadığını söyleyemez.
Bunu ancak sen bilebilirsin,
sen hissedebilirsin.
İşte bu yüzden seçilmiş kişi
olup olmadığını
ancak ve ancak sen bilebilirsin."
Neo bu sözlerin gerçekliği ve ağırlığı
karşısında büyük bir şaşkınlık yaşıyor.
E kolay değil.
Bu söz, öyle bir söz ki aynı zamanda
felsefe tarihinin ilk öğretilerinden biri.
Hatta o kadar eski ki
Yunanistan’ın Delphi bölgesindeki
Apollon Tapınağı’nın girişinde
“Temet Nosce”nin farklı bir
Latince versiyonu yazıyordu.
Ben şahsen bu sözün omuzlarda taşınması
zor bir yük olduğuna inanıyorum.
Neden mi?
Çünkü hepimiz her zaman
güçlü olduğumuza inanmak istiyoruz.
Zira öyle yetiştiriliyoruz.
Mesela ailelerimiz için
en yakışıklı, en güzel, en başarılı,
her şeyin en iyisini
hak eden bizler değil miyiz?
Tabi tutulduğumuz eğitim sistemi
bize sadece başarı hikâyeleri sunmuyor mu?
Peki ya iş hayatımız?
Her şeyin en iyisini bilen,
en doğrusunu yapan,
her terfiyi hak eden
yine bizler değil miyiz?
Seyrettiğimiz filmler, diziler
bile kahramanlarla dolu.
Dünya bu kadar başarı hikâyesi
ve kahramanla doluyken
bizler nasıl başarısız olabiliriz?
Hiç düşündünüz mü?
Belki Atlantik geçişi öncesinde böyle
düşünmek bana da iyi hissettirebilirdi.
Ancak bir süredir denizcilikle ilgilenen
biri olarak şunu çok iyi biliyordum:
"Okyanus böyle blöfleri yemezdi."
Kendimi kandırabilirdim,
ama onu asla kandıramazdım.
Bir şekilde tüm zaaflarımla,
tüm eksi yönlerimle yüzleşip
kendimi olduğum gibi
kabul etmek durumundaydım.
Başta bu yaklaşımın beni
oldukça zorlayacağını düşünmüştüm.
Ancak zaman içerisinde beni
daha güçlü kıldığını fark ettim.
Evet, “Kendini bilmek” bir klişe
olmaktan çıkmış,
beni hafifletmeye bile başlamıştı.
E şimdi haklı olarak soracaksınız.
Kendini bildin de ne oldu diye.
Hemen söyleyeyim.
Koskoca Atlantik Okyanusu’nu
tek başıma geçmemin
çok mantıksız olduğuna karar verdim.
Açık deniz tecrübem vardı,
uzun rotalar yapmıştım
ancak hiç okyanus aşırı
bir tecrübem olmamıştı.
İşte bu noktada
benim eksilerimi tamamlayabilecek
benden daha tecrübeli bir ekibe
mürettebat olarak katılmamın
daha doğru olduğunu fark ettim ve
araştırmalarımı bu yönde yoğunlaştırdım.
Sonunda internetten
Ekber ve Gülin’i buldum.
Ekber ve Gülin, okyanusaşırı
tecrübesi olan bir çiftti ve
Karayipler’in St. Maarteen Adası’ndan
Portekiz’in Lagoş kentine doğru
bir geçiş planlıyorlardı.
Kendilerine e-postayla ulaştım.
Planlamalarımızı yaptık
ve ben St. Maarteen’e gittim.
Bu arada onları hiç tanımıyordum bile.
Hatta havalimanına ilk indiğimde
“Merhaba ben Emre,
merhaba biz de Gülin ve Ekber”
diye tokalaştığımızı anımsıyorum.
Ancak bunu takip eden 10 gün içerisinde
hem teknemizin bakımlarını yapma,
hem teknemizi geliştirme
hem de biraz birbirimizi
tanıma şansımız olmuştu.
Ekber, çok enteresan bir kişilikti.
Hayatı denizlerde geçmişti ve çok babacan,
çok soğukkanlı bir karakteri vardı.
Karadaki hazırlıklarımız sırasında
yaşadığımız problemlerde
ekibi sakinleştiren, çözüm üreten
genelde Ekber oluyordu.
Gülin’in de kendinden emin
bir duruşu vardı.
Hatta Gülin için şu an Türkiye’de
en fazla okyanus geçmiş kadın dememiz
yanlış olmayacaktır diye düşünüyorum.
Ekip olarak birbirimizi yakından tanıdıkça
ortak zamanlarımız da
daha keyifli geçmeye başladı
ve zaman su gibi akıp geçti.
Adadaki son günümüze geldik.
Son günümüzde St. Maarteen’in
Philipsburg limanına demir attık.
Harikulade bir yerdi!
Her şeyden önce heyecan doruktaydı.
Dile kolay ben bir gün sonra hayalimdeki
o seyahate başlayabilecektim.
Ekber ve Gülin erkenden
dinlenmeye çekildiler.
Benim de bu zorlu seyahat öncesinde
enerji toplayabilmek için
erkenden uyumam gerekiyordu.
Ama, uyuyamadım.
Çok stresliydim.
Saat 4’e kadar gözümün bir ucu karada
“Emre acaba böyle bir maceraya
girmesen de karaya mı kaçsan?”
diye kendimi sorgulayıp durdum.
İşte o gece, okyanus bana harekete geçme
formülünün ikinci maddesini fısıldadı:
“Konfor alanını terk et!”
Konfor alanını şöyle tanımlayabiliriz:
İnsanın hali hazırda aşina
hissettiği bir ortamda,
her şeyi kontrol edebileceği
yanılgısına düştüğü
ve kendisini rahat hissettiği
psikolojik evre.
Aslında bu kavram insanlık tarihiyle
yaşıt bile diyebiliriz.
Ancak konfor alanına ilk dikkat
çekenlerden biri Platon olmuş.
Platon "Devlet" adlı eserinde kaleme
almış olduğu "Mağara Alegorisi" ile
bu konuda önemli tespitlerde bulunmuş.
Hikâye, doğdukları andan itibaren
bir mağarada mahkûm edilen
insanları konu alıyor.
Bu insanlar yüzleri dönük olacak
şekilde zincirleniyorlar.
Ama öyle bir zincirleniyorlar ki yanlarına
dönüp diğer mahkûmları göremiyorlar bile.
Tek görebildikleri duvardaki o gölgeler.
Duydukları bütün sesleri
o gölgelerle eşleştiriyorlar
ve aslında onlar için dünya
sadece ve sadece o gölgelerden ibaret.
Gün geliyor, mahkûmlardan biri
zincirlerini kırmayı başarıyor.
Ürke ürke mağaranın çıkışına doğru
ilerliyor ve güneşle tanışıyor.
Güneşin o güçlü ışıkları gözlerini
öyle bir acıtıyor ki
başta büyük bir refleksle
gözlerini kapıyor.
Gözlerini tekrar açtığındaysa,
bu sefer zihnindeki
zincirleri kırmayı başarıyor.
Zira karşısında bambaşka
dünya olduğunu görüyor.
Hikâyenin mesajı çok net:
Konfor alanının dışına çıkmazsan
değişemezsin,
değişemezsen geleceğin parçası olamazsın.
Evet o güven çemberinin içerisinde olmak
bizleri rahat hissettiriyor olabilir.
Ancak yeni tecrübelerin o çizginin
ötesinde olduğunu düşündüğümüzde
aslında o alan hepimiz için değişememe
riskini de beraberinde getiriyor.
Bu hikayeyi hatırlamak
gözlerimi “acaba kaçsam mı”
diyerek baktığım karadan,
tekrar açık denizlere
çevirmemi sağlamıştı.
Ve evet, belki de o kara parçası
benim kendi mağaramdı.
Ve içimde hissettiğim şey aslında
stres değildi, heyecandı.
Daha önce hiç yaşamadığım
bir şeyi tecrübe edecektim.
Ve kalbimin gümbür gümbür atması
çok ama çok normaldi.
İşte bu düşünceler,
yaptığımız hazırlıklar,
3 kişiden oluşsa bile bir takımın
parçası olduğumu hissetmek
beni rahatlatmaya başlamıştı.
Sonunda heyecanımla barışabildim
ve bambaşka bir hayata gözlerimi
açmak üzere kamarama çekildim.
Ve sabah oldu, o büyük an geldi çattı.
O gün ne kadar heyecanlı
olduğumu size anlatamam.
Hayalimdeki seyahate başlamak
üzere demir aldık
ve St. Maarteen’den okyanusun o uçsuz
bucaksız ufkuna doğru seyretmeye başladık.
Hava tam istediğimiz gibiydi.
Planımız St. Maarteen’den
Azorlar’a varmak,
Azorlar’da birkaç gün dinlendikten sonra
Portekiz’in Lagoş kentine ulaşarak
seyahatimizi sonlandırmaktı.
Her şeyi de düşünmüştük,
vardiyalar halinde çalışıyorduk.
Vardiyalarımız dışında,
teknemizdeki küçük işlerimizi halledip
dinlenmeye çekiliyorduk.
Her sabah uydudan meteorolojik
raporumuzu alıp çalışmalar yapıyorduk.
Sonrasında günlük rotamızda
küçük rötuşlar yapabiliyorduk.
Her şey kontrolümüz altındaydı
ve planladığımız gibi gidiyordu.
Ta ki bir gün hava şartları
değişene kadar…
O sabah uydudan aldığımız raporda
yaklaşık 2-3 derece kuzey enlemimizde
bir fırtına oluşumu gözüküyordu.
Biz kuzey doğuya doğru
ilerlerken ani bir kararla
rotamızı güney doğuya
kırmak zorunda kaldık.
O fırtınadan kaçınmak zorundaydık,
bu çok netti.
Ancak yeni rotamız aynı zamanda
hedeflerimizden uzaklaşmamız
anlamına da geliyordu.
İki üç gün bu yönde ilerledikten sonra
haritamızı açtık
ve bir değerlendirme yaptık.
O günkü koordinatlarımıza göre,
ara hedefimiz olan Azorlar’a çıkmak yerine
Madeira’ya ulaşmak
daha mantıklı gözüküyordu.
Hatta iki üç gün daha bu yönde ilerlersek
Kanarya Adaları veya
Cape Verde’ye bile ulaşabilirdik.
Planlar bozulmaya başlamıştı,
belirsizlik artıyordu.
Düşünsenize bu kadar belirsizlikle
dolu bir seyahate çıkıyorsunuz,
Avrupa’ya ulaşmayı hedefliyorsunuz ancak
gelişmeler sizi Afrika’ya yönlendiriyor.
Yani bu, ada vapurunun
Bostancı İskelesi yerine
Kadıköy İskelesi’ne
yanaşması gibi bir şey değil.
Bambaşka bir kıtadan bahsediyorum.
Açıkçası bu belirsizlik
beni yiyip bitirmişti.
Ekber ve Gülin benden çok
daha rahat gözüküyorlardı
ancak ilk fırsatta Ekber’e gidip
tepkimi şöyle dile getirdim:
“Ekber, hani Azorlar’a varacaktık?
Portekiz’e nasıl gideceğiz?
Hiçbir şey planladığımız
gibi gitmiyor, neler oluyor?”
Sanki kurumsal Emre tekrar canlanmıştı da
“Ne demek planlarımıza uyamıyoruz?
Ne demek hedeflerimize ulaşamıyoruz?”
diye serzenişte bulunuyordu.
Buna karşılık Ekber bana
her zamanki soğukkanlılığıyla
çok net bir cevap vermişti:
“Emreciğim, hava şartları değişti.
N’apalım fırtınaya mı girelim?
Bu hiçbirimizin kontrol
edebileceği bir şey değil.
Ayrıca bizim nihai hedefimiz
okyanusu geçmek,
Portekiz’e varmak değil ki.
Biz hedefimize varmak için
rotamızı değiştirdik sadece.
Sakin olabilirsin.”
Okyanus bu sefer Ekber vasıtasıyla
bana harekete geçme formülünün
3. Maddesini fısıldamıştı:
Çakıl taşı gibi ol!
Çakıl taşının hikayesini bilirsiniz.
O da aslında diğer bütün taşlar gibi
kendisine has köşesi, şekli olan
bir kaya parçasıdır.
Zaman içerisinde doğaya maruz kalır,
parçalanıp ayrılıp yok olmak yerine
köşelerinin aşınmasına izin verir.
Şeklini değiştirerek var olmaya devam eder
ama özünü hiçbir zaman kaybetmez.
O her zaman için bir taştır.
Bir de hani “Temet Nosce”de
bahsetmiştik ya,
Hepimiz gerçekten güçlü olduğumuza
inanmak istiyoruz diye.
İnsanoğlu aynı zamanda,
her şeyin kontrol edebildiği yanılgısına
da düşmeyi de seviyor.
Çünkü bu bizi rahat hissettiriyor.
Bu şekilde kendimize ait bir
konfor alanı tanımlayabiliyoruz.
Ama sizi temin ederim:
Okyanus, o bizim kurgularla dolu özel veya
iş hayatlarımızdan bambaşka bir ortamdı.
Her şeyden önce bizden
çok daha kuvvetliydi.
Ona kafa tutma ihtimalimiz bile yoktu.
Ayrıca, kontrol edilemezdi.
Bizim kontrol edebildiğimiz şeyler
teknemizle sınırlıydı.
Dümenimiz, yelkenlerimiz,
vinçlerimiz, halatlarımız vs.
Ve o an için yapmamız gereken
en mantıklı hareket
okyanusu doğru okuyup onu doğru anlamak
ve kontrol edebildiğimiz unsurlarla
ona ayak uydurmaktı.
Burada bir parantez açmak istiyorum.
Sizce de hayatımızda kontrol duygusu
gereğinden fazla ağır basmıyor mu?
Hatta bazen daha fazla şey
kontrol edebilelim diye
beklemeyi tercih edip harekete
geçmeyi ertelemiyor muyuz?
Sizce de aslında okyanus,
hayatın ta kendisi değil mi?
Biliyorum bunu söylemek çok kolay,
idrak edebilmekse çok daha zor.
En azından okyanusta
benim için öyle olmuştu.
Bunu anlamam zaman aldı ama
bunu özümseyebildiğim an,
içimdeki o gerginlik, o canavar gibi
uyanan kurumsal Emre ile beraber
tekrar uçup gitti ve yerini
o tatlı heyecana bıraktı.
Ve sonra ne oldu biliyor musunuz?
Hava şartları da düzeldi,
bizim şansımız yaver gitti
ve biz Azorlar’a varabildik.
Azorlar’da teknemizin tamiratlarını
yaptık, erzaklarımızı yeniledik.
Birkaç gün dinlendikten sonra
Portekiz Lagoş’a doğru yelken açtık.
Ben yaklaşık 30 gün süren
bir seyahat sonrasında
hayallerimden birini gerçekleştirmiştim.
Ve bu benim için sadece
bir başlangıç olmuştu.
Çünkü, artık hayatta nasıl harekete
geçebileceğimi çok iyi biliyordum.
Ve bunu hayatımın her alanına
uygulamaya başladım.
Hatta bugün kendimi insanları ve
şirketleri harekete geçirmeye adadım.
Bu, benim hikayemdi.
Kim bilir sizin nasıl hikayeleriniz var.
Belki siz de benzer tecrübeler edindiniz
ve bu süreçte kendinize
has yeni değerler keşfettiniz.
Belki de henüz öyle bir şansınız olmadı.
Eğer olmadıysa lütfen duraksamayın.
Keşkelerin bedelinin
çok ağır olduğu bu hayatta,
şu üç maddeli formüllü kullanın:
1. Kendinizi iyi tanıyın
2. Konfor alanınızın dışına
çıkma cesaretini gösterin.
3. Çakıl taşı gibi olun, dış dünyaya
adapte olun ve kendinizi gerçekleştirin.
İsmini hiç hatırlayamadığım,
görsem bile telaffuz edemediğim
Danimarkalı bir filozof var.
Bir de onun hiç unutmadığım şu güzel sözü:
“Hayat geriye bakarak anlaşılır,
ileriye bakarak yaşanır.”
Geçmişe odaklanarak,
onunla gurur duyarak
geleceğin ancak ve ancak
izleyicisi olabiliriz.
Ama eğer o güven çemberinin
dışına çıkıp
yeni tecrübeler edinme cesareti
gösterebilirsek
işte o zaman kendi çapımızda da olsa
geleceğimizi şekillendirmeye
başlayabiliriz.
Ben bunun insana çok farklı bir güç
katacağına inanıyorum.
Nasıl bir güç mü?
Bazen çok zor bir durumla karşılaştığımda
ve düşüncelere daldığımda
eşim Deniz bana şöyle der:
“Emre, yapma ama… Okyanus geçmiş insansın,
bununla mı baş edemeyeceksin”
Benim bahsettiğim
“Bunu başardıysam,
her şeyi başarabilirim”
tarzında bir güç değil aslında.
Benim anlatmaya çalıştığım,
hayatımızın herhangi bir anında,
herhangi bir alanında rahatlıkla
harekete geçebileceğimizi
ve geleceğimizi
şekillendirebileceğimizi bilme gücü.
O yüzden durmayın!
Bir hayaliniz, bir tutkunuz mu var?
Harekete geçin!
İşinizde veya hayatınızda daha güzel,
daha iyi şeyler yaparak
bir şeyleri değiştirebileceğinize mi
inanıyorsunuz?
Harekete geçin!
Sizce dünya daha yaşanılabilir
bir yer mi olabilir?
Harekete geçin!
Ve Şems-i Tebrizi’nin o
sözlerini unutmayın,
Her insan ölecek yaşta…
Sakın ha geç kalmayın…
Çok teşekkür ederim!